parents searching for answers this
morning after they say they were
notified that their kids were high on
marijuana edibles at school this
happened friday over at quest prep
academy near craig and rancho houston
spoke with one of those parents who says
there needs to be better emergency
protocols
i'm very upset i'm angry jenae simmelton
says her daughter ate an edible but was
not told until after that it contained
marijuana simpleton says this happened
in the morning and parents didn't know
until they tried to pick up their kids
there were probably
maybe four other parents there waiting
for the same reasons
they're not letting us see our kids talk
to them and have them call it all day
simpleton says kids were asleep on the
ground crying and one throwing up
indicating paramedics should have been
called simultan says she tried to speak
to the principal but was told she was
not available due to a holiday party she
says they did communicate hours later
but says more needs to be done knowing
that multiple kids were involved in
taking these edibles whether they were
their fault or not knowing or not once
you realize as an adult and as a parent
possibly
you should seek medical attention
simultan plans to contact the state
public charter school authority which
oversees quest academy saying stricter
safety measures need to be in place we
have to be the voices for our kids
whether they're right or wrong
the leadership at the school
failed us and failed them kate houston
live local now
we reached out to quest prep academy as
well as the state public charter school
authority asking for more information on
their drug safety protocols we haven't
heard back yet